I'm going to lead you through the
process that I went through to arrive at
my solution not just give you my
solution okay so here's where I began
this is just all given to you this is
what I'm required to prove okay so
you're already sorry on the one that I
held up right the problem with this
diagram is that even before I put
anything on to it
it is wildly complicated there's lots of
stuff on there so I have to do
everything I can to make clear what I am
trying to prove
okay so CPR where's that triangle it's
up the top there okay so here's my
target so I make it really clear and by
the way like I've said this before I'm
like oh if you have colors colors
legitimately add something to your
ability to solve this question which is
why when I gave this solution to some of
you I gave my original not a photocopy
because this communicates something a
photocopy would not there's and it's
pretty this is one triangle bdq that's
this guy over here can you share okay
maybe for you yeah it's this very thin
triangle in here which reaches outside
the parallelogram you with me okay so
this is three this is tricky you'll
notice they have phrases in a very
particular way this is not a congruence
proof even though a confidence proof is
usually what would imply this now the
fact that they phrased this to you in
this way tells you it won't just be that
straightforward
okay secondly if there are areas how
many ways do you know how to find the
area of a triangle and the answer is you
know two ways right what's the first way
you learn back in yourself area equals
1/2 base times perpendicular height
right that's one way okay your other way
of course is
you've learned all this fancy tricks top
right which allows you this other method
now just pause for a second look at the
triangles that you have don't shout it
out don't shout it out just think it
through being that these your own tools
for working out area right which of
these is more likely to be a better fit
for the information that you've been
given and by the way pretty much the
only thing is those two equal science
you see that like that's the only
special thing and it's a parallelogram
okay so you were given a scant amount of
information now which do you lean
towards I'll tell you now if you haven't
already arrived at this it's this guy
but please let me tell you why there are
two big clues okay number one
perpendicular hunt
how many perpendicular heights do you
see on this diagram and son none right
now that doesn't mean that doesn't mean
it's out of the running in fact in a
second I'm going to introduce a
perpendicular height and I'm going to
use it but it does sort of lead you away
from them secondly when you have a look
at this right you see it has an angle in
it right now usually angles are kind of
like well when you first let this angle
is didn't even factor into working out
area the reason why angle is probably
going to be extraordinarily useful here
is for the sole reason that you have a
parallelogram parallelograms by
necessity give you equal angles
everywhere right it's a little bit like
circles they just jump out at you
because it's such a special kind of
shape so that's what leads me in this
direction you see that okay now being
that this is the direction I'm going to
lean in this transforms the question for
me a little bit right because now I can
state the area of each of these in terms
of this formula right it's more than one
way to say it but for an example right
you go through the iterations do you
think okay
side C right I can pick if I think about
Cpl I can pick any one of those angles
as my angle and then I get two other
sides right now which do you think might
be the most useful angle remember I've
got to go from green to red or red to
green right for me the thing that jumps
out of me is this a glean here
now I know that's not immediately
obvious but for me the reason why that's
the the clearest one is because it has
the closest relationship to anything
else over here do you see that like I've
got vertically opposite there I pretty
much have to stretch for anything to get
anything in those corner angles okay you
will have noticed I'm pretty sure most
people put like the parallel lines on
there I have chosen not to your number
one because I feel it's obvious number
two I'm actually trying to put as little
onto the diagram as possible it's one of
those less is more type situations you
can put autum million angles here in
their relationships and it just clouds
the proof it doesn't make any clearer
does that make sense
so I have that angle now how would I
then state the area of that triangle up
there if that was the angle that I was
working with
it's a match you happy with it that
would have to be what I do if that was
the angular Church okay now that's
correct that is correct it's one way of
stating it but the reason why this is so
useful
okay is because you like okay an angle
right if I can prove that this angle is
equal to an angle in this triangle then
I can sort that up and we have to look
at this all right
this is why it's it's kind of neat that
I've gone to this case do you remember
on Wednesday you looked at things like
this
you remember this right what statement
what equation could you draw in terms of
the relationships of these intercepts
what would you like to see maybe equals
see it's a product products or
intercepts or intersecting chords are
equal but you know and I gave you a
really really quick intro that the proof
of this had nothing to do with products
does it right what does it have to do it
has to do with similarity which gives
you ratios right what did we said it
well you'd get a triangle like B right
so you're getting a pair of triangles
like like this okay so being that you
have a product here you have product
right you should be strongly inclined to
the fact of being you have you're gonna
expect angles to be equal they're really
this product is actually a ratio in
disguise okay now at this point at this
point like literally this is when it
clicked for me like that once I'd
written this down then I'm you which
direction I had to go in okay so that
was right clicked for me so now I'm
going to start my proof okay here's what
I'm going to do I chose to go from green
to red okay so I've got triangle what do
we call it B D Q okay
now the area of this triangle I wonder
if you can see but is exactly no I'm
gonna use come it's exactly the same as
the area of this triangle now can you
see why it's a lot of immediately
obvious you have a parallelogram right
and it's been on this line is being
produced out with which means that it
stays parallel so mark tell me why
they're equal okay if I put but put in
and I I have to do this in my proof in a
second if I put in a perpendicular
height of this parallelogram right the
perpendicular height of this
parallelogram is the same as the
perpendicular height of all the
triangles that I form between here and
here
does that make sense right so being that
they had the same perpendicular height
and they have the same base the areas
are equal
does that make sense so let me start
writing it I'm going to say let the and
this is the way so I'm going to go
through the proof of length let the
perpendicular height of the
parallelogram because that's where I'm
constructing everything off
let the perpendicular height of ABCD be
H it's not on there yet so I'm just
gonna draw them okay therefore I can say
the area of triangle BD is equal to half
base that's thank you
right by definition okay but then I can
say that's equal to 1/2 B Q is given to
be equal to B P right half be P times
but yeah if you following so that is
this black dot a triangle in the middle
B P D